bonsoir à tous je suis ravi d'être ici
vous savez quoi l'éducation va connaître
une révolution sans précédent
et cette révolution père sans précédent
a permis à permettre une renaissance de
notre épanouissement personnel et de nos
modes de vie notre épanouissement
personnel parlons-en
est ce que je pourrais avoir mon
parlons-en lundi matin 7 heures qui
parmi vous heureux d'aller travailler de
mettre tout son talent au profit de la
société du bien commun super peut-être
que vous êtes étudiants en vacances
bon écoute et sachez qu'il ya 80% des
personnes qui sont malheureux dans leur
job mais c'est pas grave parce qu'en
fait il ya les chinois et les machines
qui vont bientôt nous remplacer donc il
va falloir trouver certaines
alternatives en fait manger pendant pas
mal d'années chercher un job qui me
plairait pour ce qu on dit que quand on
trouve un job qui nous plaît on n'a plus
à travailler un jour de sa vie et j'ai
mis trente ans avant de découvrir ma
passion ma passion qui est l'accès à
l'éducation pour le plus grand nombre
il n'y a pas si longtemps je quittais
des bancs de la fac va de l'école pour
entamer un tour du monde
j'entendais beaucoup parler de
réchauffement climatique mais très peu
de réchauffement sociale sachez que dans
le monde il ya quatre milliards de gens
qui vivent avec moins de deux dollars
par jour et qui ont des besoins
essentiels le besoin d'accès à l'eau à
la santé au logement à l'éducation aux
nouvelles technologies aux transports
alors je suis allé étudier pendant un an
une cinquantaine d'entreprises qui
essayait de lutter contre la pauvreté
tout en étant rentable arriver à
l'équilibré en design ont des produits
pour les plus pauvres
j'ai vu plein de projet fascinant des
langues qui se remonte à la manivelle
qui remplace les lampes au kérosène qui
coûte cher qui polluent qui créent des
incidents domestiques
j'ai vu aussi des initiatives dans le
domaine de l'accès à l'eau une
microstation d'épuration au cambodge qui
coûte pas plus de 5000 euros qui permet
par 200 pour 2 centimes par mois
donner accès à l'eau à une famille tous
les mois et donc d'empêcher toutes les
maladies liesse suivi des domaines des
des formidables initiatives dans le
domaine de de la vue ou pour 3 dollars
au bangladesh vous pouvoir 3 souvent le
feu ophtalmologiques une paire de
lunettes en fait peut-être que les
entreprises françaises dont la graine en
tirer de ce genre d'initiatives pour
baisser un petit peu les prix voilà
l'objectif de ce voyage aussi s'était
fait réfléchir les étudiants en les
mettant dans la peau d'un dirigeant au
bangladesh qui devait vendre des
produits lui pour permettre une
alimentation saine ultra accessible
voilà l avantage c'était qu'il y avait
un vrai défi intellectuel parce qu'il
fallait gérer la corruption la chaîne
logistique ainsi de suite et j'ai fait
ça parce que je pensais que les
étudiants avaient le droit aussi de
découvrir ce que c'était de mettre les
pieds dans le quotidien des gens qui va
clairement avec moins de 4 dollars par
jour
à l'issue de ce voyage en fait il y eut
plusieurs constats plusieurs réflexions
notamment que les gens sont pauvres
parce qu'ils sont ignorants et pour
sortir les gens de la pauvreté il faut
deux choses à la base
flex et à l'éducation l'accès au capital
au microcrédit pour le microcrédit ya
mohamed muhammad yunus et toute sa bande
qui s'en occupe en revanche pour l'accès
à l'éducation il ya très peu de choses
est très peu de chose quand on va au
mali exemple sur les routes on voit que
dans des villages très peu peuplée ya
cette école qui sont construites vierge
désertent les professeurs sont partis
ils ont été formés par une ong six mois
puis sont partis il reste des caisses de
livres avec l'histoire de la reine
d'angleterre
l'histoire des dinosaures est ce que
vous croyez vraiment que c'est celle
dont on entend les gens sur place
est-ce qu'ils auraient pas besoin plutôt
d'apprendre à régler leurs chants
vacciner leurs chèvres construire un
habitat plus décent ouvrir micro servant
de coiffure ouvrir une micro boulangerie
donc là il y avait un chantier énorme
ça a commencé à travailler dans mon
esprit est de retour en france j'ai
constaté qu'en fait il y avait un oeil
parce que nos sociétés
ce que je souhaitais à ces pays là
comme le sierra leone le soudan cuba
inquiétude c'est qu'ils se développent
tous aussi bien qu'ils prospèrent tous
aussi bien que nous les français les
américains
sauf que ce qui va pas c'est que dans le
nôtre frénésie consommatrice et on peut
pas empêcher les chinois ou les
habitants de battambang de vouloir avoir
accès à une motorbike un téléphone ils
vont faire on va nous attend des
endroits aussi à cette forme de liberté
problème c'est que s'ils se mettent à
tous consommé comme nous une planète ne
suffira pas il en faudra quatre donc est
ce qu'il faut souhaiter le progrès pour
tous et juin ça c'est le plan 1
le plan de en fait ce serait de de nous
offrir l'opportunité de vivre dix fois
mieux avec moins de ressources
alors pour ça il ya plusieurs choses et
l'accès à une bonne éducation
l'accès aux technologies et d'accès à
l'intelligence collaborative qui vont
nous permettre de d'opérer ce changement
de société est en fait mon conseil
s'était pas de savoir si j'étais
optimiste ou pessimiste par rapport à la
situation les jambes dieuze que t'es pas
trop déconnecté tout ça non je me suis
jamais s'ils sont sentis aussi connecté
quand on parlait de pauvreté ainsi de
suite j'ai juste constater qu' il veut
des pauvres aussi en france les pauvres
aussi aux états unis pour moi les gens
pauvres sont sur les gens en situation
de dépendance
les gens en situation de dépendance y en
a beaucoup en france on peut être malade
on peut divorcer on peut être incapable
de gérer ses relations en entreprise
ainsi de suite alors j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser au futur de l'éducation à
la renaissance de l'éducation la
renaissance de l'éducation pour moi
c'est à passer par l'internet
les nouvelles technologies ce qu'il a
trois milliards de personnes aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont connectés et qu'ils ont
accès l'information et les autres arrêts
aussi il ya de formidable initiative
notamment les mots qu'on parle beaucoup
des mots qu massive open online pour 6
des cours de stanford harvard incident
qui sont diffusées en ligne
honnêtement c'est court là qui dure 16
heures à qui ils sont destinés sont
souvent destinés aux mbiye l 100 clients
des masters ceux qui savent parler
anglais
il ya sept milliards d'habitants qui
n'ont pas besoin de ces cours là ils
n'ont pas vocation à devenir trader
devenir spécialiste des nanotechnologies
à devenir politicien
non les gens pètent cherche une
éducation une bonne éducation pour être
heureux pour une certaine joie de vivre
et qu'est ce qui fait la joie de vivre
au fait c'est pas forcément l'accès aux
savoirs académiques les maths la
physique
l'anglais ainsi de suite c'est aussi
accès au savoir faire et savoir être
quand vous regardez à la fin de votre
semaine ce qui vous a rendu heureux
c'est quand vous à jouer de la guitare
quand vous êtes réconcilier avec votre
femme quand vous avez cuisine et un bon
plat quand vous avez jardiner bricoler
c'est tous ces moments là en fait ils
font les jeux de vivre et ça passe par
du savoir-faire et le savoir-être et
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
dispensé à l'école
il faut savoir que il ya 50%
il va manquer de 50% de professeurs dans
les pays en voie de développement donc
pour ceux qui se posent la question oui
mais ce n'est pas pareil que les
professeurs ont ainsi de suite la
l'accès à l'éducation pour les nouvelles
technologies est fondamental et je pense
que l'accès à une bonne éducation qui
passe par le savoir-faire le savoir être
et le savoir
c'est ça qui fait l'accès à une bonne
éducation et c'est selon table dans 5
milliards d'habitants sur terre
c'est un marché juste gigantesque donc
une vraie vraie opportunité de business
ou pas alors moi j'ai rêvé d'une école
où les gens avaient accès librement un
tas de savoir j'ai rêvé d'une école où
il y avait une vraie curiosité une vraie
volonté d'apprendre une vraie joie
d'apprendre
plutôt que de subir gervais d'une école
où les professeurs inspirait allumé des
feux auprès des élèves et dans le coeur
des plutôt que d'une école où les élèves
sont finalement des seaux d'eau qu'on
remplit de savoir que mon ballon serait
de 2 des connaissances comme ça j'ai
rêvé d'un lieu qui serait disponible
uniquement si la personne en a la
volonté la volonté sera la seule
barrière qui serait pas dépendante des
revenus qui seraient pas des vents est
dépendante du lieu géographique il
serait pas dépendante du pays ou autre
j'ai rêvé d'un lieu où les gens
pourraient développer tout leur
potentiel n'est pas que leur potentiel
académique en matant physique en chimie
nous allons pouvoir développer vraiment
leur savoir faire et peut-être découvrir
la vraie passion alors j'ai créé six
canes un scanner c'est un outil simple
pour acquérir des centaines de savoir
faire qui améliorent la vie des gens
sainement et simplement un moment je
joue pas on dispense des milliers de
cours aux quatre coins du monde qui a
d'aussi bien des gens dans les pays en
voie de développement que déjà en france
lisez 5 à 50 euros ou 5 5 milliards à la
fin du mois il voilà ce que ce que ça
donne
à
m
en fait si cana c'est un mix entre khan
academy et aide mais pour les savoir
faire pratique et vocationnelle on a
commencé c'était pas facile j'ai
rencontré un ami qui était caméraman
puis on s'est associés on a commencé
dans une chambre de bonne
puis dans un garage qui celle qui
faisait office de studio fond dans un
sous-sol à paris petit à petit d'autres
personnes nous ont rejoints et
commencent à former une équipe mettre
quelques vidéos sur youtube a attiré
quelques experts et puis de plus en plus
on s'est mis à produire des vidéos dans
d'autres pays
avoir des gens de toutes nationalités
différentes qui nous ont rejoints
aujourd'hui on a produit 2300 vidéo
qu'on dit qu'on est en train de traduire
dans 10 langues
on a dispensé 15 millions de cours et
tout ça on l'a fait avec des moyens
extrêmement faible pourquoi parce qu'on
n'est pas tout seul il n'y a pas qu'une
équipe de 20 personnes talentueuses de
12 nationalités différentes qui nous a
rejoints mais aussi 450 kw volontaires
qui nous ont prêté main forte
et avec ça on a pu attirer des experts
qui ont permis de transmettre des
savoirs faire dans le domaine de la
nature de l'artisanat de la beauté de
l'art et tous avaient un très bon triple
impact chez nous un remédier à
l'injustice l'égalité des opportunités
pour tous de empêcher que des choses
bien disparaissent en préservant les
héritages culturels étroits améliorer
durablement la vie des gens et derrière
chaque programme pédagogique ont réuni
un panel d'experts là ici c'est le
programme nature on a réuni en excès un
panel d'experts mondialement connu il ya
un prix nobel
karabi jones evans ainsi de suite on a
tourné une première vidéo aux etats-unis
qui permettent de faire pousser une
alimentation saine sans intrants
chimiques ni pesticides
l'objectif de ce programme ont fait il
est il et permettre à tous d'avoir une
alimentation saine et pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui et 75 % de la
biodiversité de la biodiversité
potagères et fruitières qui a disparu il
ya 99% de semences qui se
des hybrides f1 donc des semences qui
sont infertiles qui repousse pas il ya
75 % des personnes dans les pays en voie
de développement qui travaillent la
terre
donc il ya juste un chantier énorme et
on dispose en diffusant tous ces
coureurs-là gratuitement sur comment
faire son semi récolter ces graines
ainsi de suite on est des ong à travers
nos programmes pédagogiques sur le
terrain à travers des dvd des clés usb
en inde que les gens se refile à travers
des programmes télévision en afrique
qu'on va lancer bientôt on va permettre
à tous ces gens là de retrouver une
autonomie alimentaire
c'était en train de perdre on va aussi
permettre à nous le week-end va de
retrouver le goût des bons aliments donc
ça c'est un exemple de programme mais y
en a d'autres il ya des dizaines de
programmes qui sont lancés tous les ans
et c'est en train de s'amplifier et ça
le fait pas tout seul en fait fait pas
tout seul on nous on opère sur un mode
collaboratif comme tête comme wikipédia
on trouve des gens qui veulent donner du
sens à leur vie des entreprises qui
veulent donner davantage de sens et on
arrive à fédérer ces gens là et ils
viennent pourquoi parce qu'ils s'amusent
parce qu'il donne parce qu'ils
retrouvent un impact parce qu'ils
perdent pas leur temps parce qu'ils
rencontrent des gens différents et x
raisons pour lesquelles ils viennent et
autour de la table on voulait pas faire
ça tout seul on a mis des particuliers
des ong et des fondations des
institutions des entreprises pour créer
les meilleurs programmes pédagogiques
libéré dans un maximum de langues
possibles
les entreprises viennent parce que ça
permet de démocratiser leur coeur de
métier avec davantage de personnes se
mettent à bricoler davantage de
personnes apprennent à jouer d'un
instrument ou pratiquer un sport
elles viennent aussi parce que ça permet
aussi de réaffirmer leur valeur parce
que toutes les entreprises ont une
mission à la base démocratiser les
jouets les plaisirs du sport au plus
grand nombre
rendre l'habitat accessible au plus
grand nombre la santé par l'alimentation
tout ça en longtemps et là c'est des
actions à travers six cana qui
permettent de tenir lieu qui font lieu
de discours en fait parce que chaque mot
chaque année à la fin on permet de
montrer qu'on a données réellement 50
millions de cours à des gens qui
n'avaient pas accès libre et puis les
ong aussi qu'ils nous prêtent main forte
comme la croix rouge ou d'autres qui a
soit nous donne des experts ce nous
donne des financements et ensuite sur le
terrain répondent ses savoir faire
et puis un talent particulier aussi
qu'ils nous prêtent main forte dans la
traduction dans l'étude du contenu à
produire dans leur expertise qui
commence à développer leur passion ils
sont passionnés de telle ou telle
discipline nous rejoignent autour de la
table il rencontre les experts qu'ils
auraient rêvé de rencontrer et tout ça
s'est fait en fait avec très peu de
moyens et la magie en train de s'opérer
en fait on signe de plus en plus de
partenariats ont produit plus en plus de
vidéos qui sont venues de plus en plus
donc on attire de plus en plus experts
reconnus donc on attire de plus en plus
d'audience donc on attire de plus en
plus de médias et on qu'on attire de
plus en plus de partenaires et ainsi de
suite et ainsi de suite
est ce qu'il ya de magique avec les
nouvelles technologies d'intelligence
collaborative c'est que pour un euro
investi on est capable de diffuser me
lecours et ça ça permet de créer des
milliers d'opportunités aux quatre coins
du monde
alors moi j'ai juste un souhait c'est
que vous vous rendiez sur internet que
vous commenciez à apprendre des choses
que commencer à partager les choses dans
la vraie vie que vous essayez trop notre
propre perfection des cils que vous
essayez de trouver notre propre me
everest comme j'ai pu trouver moi parce
qu'ensuite rien ne vous arrête et puis
chaque jour quand vous regardez derrière
vous vous dites waouh je dirais fait une
main un pas de plus ensuite vous êtes
affamés pour le lendemain vous êtes
rassasiés le soir et affamé pour le
lendemain et ça c'est magique et on sait
pas combien de temps on va vivre
et si jamais dans cinq ans je vais
mourir je serais ravi d'un permis à des
millions de personnes d'avoir accès aux
offres de leur avoir donné accès au
savoir faire avec toute cette communauté
alors j'ai pas de conclusion en fait
j'ai juste une introduction que vient de
faire la la suite des chapitres on va
écrire ensemble c'est ce que j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous inviter à participer à
ce mouvement global collaboratif
impactant au service d'une vie
indépendante heureuse et digne pour le
plus grand nombre
alors si vous voulez écrire la suite des
chapitres avec moi je vous invite et la
conclusion ce seront nos enfants qui
s'occuperont de l'écrire merci beaucoup